there is a
fairly well-respected scientific journal
the lancet i quote the lancet and
research from the landsat
often on this show
the lancet just came out with its new
cover for its latest issue
the cover says quote
historically it's just a white
background and then you got the quote on
the cover historically the anatomy and
physiology of bodies with vaginas have
been neglected
what
the conservatives here
are outraged
because the lancet embraces
transgenderism right they're saying well
it's not just women who possess that
body part but it's
it's ev everybody men
people who identify as men or
non-gendered or this or that or any of
the 57 genders so conservatives are
outraged that the scientific journal
embraces this unscientific concept of
transgenderism
feminists are outraged
that this journal
seems to erase women right it's no
forget about women it's bodies with this
particular anatomical feature
and furthermore that it defines women by
their anatomy
and how dare you eyes up here buddy i'm
more than just my body parts right the
most shocking part though
is that this journal is defining all of
us
as
bodies this is weird i am not just a
body i can't believe this is really
basic stuff that our culture's gotten so
stupid on that we don't recognize this
anymore
we are more than just our bodies we are
soul and spirit too we're not just meat
puppets we're not just flesh we have
minds
okay you've got the materialist heresy
on one hand which is the the idea that
we're just meat puppets then you've got
the transgender gnostic heresy on the
other the idea that our bodies have
nothing to do with who we are and then
you've got the normal obvious common
sense
true understanding of human nature which
is that we are both
you know tony heasy coates who is an
extremely overrated race hustling author
he
he loves to use this phrase black bodies
he says the black body is very oppressed
as if black people don't have souls
no it's it's
more than that buddy we are a human
person
but because we
are so insanely focused on this stuff on
the on the physical we lose sight of
that this is this is actually it ties in
with the racial thing
we're so focused on on the physical that
we think that racism is the only evil in
the world because our understanding of
sin and grace and morality only goes
skin-deep so the the editor-in-chief of
the lancet came out he's he sort of
apologized but then he defended it
because he said trans people face stigma
transgender health is very important and
of course he doesn't mean
fixing the problem or even acknowledging
it when a man thinks he's a woman or
vice versa he means affirming people in
their delusions this is the state of
modern medical science the religion
that so many leftists ascribe to the
official religion of the state of new
york now where we need apostles of their
religion we need people to wear the
religious totems of that religion i'm so
glad that you like that clip that makes
me feel
really good you can leave me a comment
here on youtube you can subscribe on
youtube but the thing that i would love
most
is if you would go to apple podcast
spotify stitch or google play type in
the
michael knowles show
subscribe leave a five star review we'll
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you